Good afternoon everyone.
Welcome to our latest webinar on API keys.
We have been talking about API keys for a
while and it's been an interesting journey
for all of us.
We learned a lot from talking with all of
you about keys and your use cases and requirements.
We are now prepared to move forward with implementation.
If you have not had a chance to look at our
previous webinars, the most recent was in
April of this year, I encourage you to go
to our webinar site on the main NCBI home
page, click on Learn and webinars and you
will find them there.
Also on the YouTube site.
You can catch up on what we talked about before.
I won't repeat all the information.
It's all available to you.
I want to do a quick review to make sure we
are at least on the basic page which is similar
of understanding.
We will talk about the current sandbox in
place now for you to test the keys.
We will hammer home what is happening now
as far as the status and what you should expect.
Also what is coming, testing periods and the
full release of functional keys in production.
This is a reminder of what the E-Utilities
do.
The point of the slide is to confirm the fact
this is only applied to E-Utilities and not
any other APIs at NCBI, such as the BLAST
or variation services API.
It just affects the E-utilities but it affects
all of them, esarch, esummary, efetch, elink,
epost.
These are unique strings that identify either
a user or piece of software to our APIs.
Keys need to be included in every API request
and they are attached to an NCBI account,
one key per account.
The idea is that with a key we will enable
you to have increased access to servers in
exchange for some information about usage
with the servers and your software.
It will help us all make APIs more stable
and reliable.
They are freely available to the public.
Free without any regulation leads to overuse
and abuse at times, so we like we would have
them available 24/7 fairly and openly so establishing
keys let's us monitor that and make sure we
can provide that level of service for everyone.
You get a key very simply by going to NCBI
account.
You may know this as a MyNCBI account, it's
the same thing, but you go and log in and
there will be a button which says create an
API key on the main page of your account.
If you click it you get a key which is a string
and copy it and put it in your code.
You have one key per NCBI account.
If you have multiple keys you need to make
multiple NCBI accounts.
How do you use it?
It's pretty simple.
In all the E-utilities there is a parameter
called &api underscore key, and you assign
your key to that parameter and you put that
in all your different requests and you are
done.
That's all you have to do.
If you are an EDirect user there is an environmental
variable named NCBI underscore API underscore
KEY and I show it on the screen.
You set that environmental variable to your
key and you are done.
You don't have to do anything else.
EDirect is intelligent and insert your key
into all requests you have.
If you don't like your key and think someone
has stolen it, whatever the issue, you can
replace it but remember if you do that your
old key is immediately deactivated so no chance
of you having more than one key on it account
at any particular time.
What is available to test is what we call
the sandbox.
The sandbox has the URL you see on the screen.
https://api.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/eutils/
If you use this sandbox, you will find your
keys are always active.
They are active in the way that they will
be once they are fully in production.
This is a great way to test the way your keys
are acting, how your software is managing
the keys and managing error responses they
receive from the keys.
I placed a couple example URLs at the bottom
of the screen.
https://api.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/eutils/esearch.fcgi?db=pubmed&term=lung
https://api.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/eutils/efetch.fcgi?db=protein&id=15718680
All you have to do is that and provide your
API key and you are running on the sandbox.
It's available now and has been available
the last coiple months.
Please use that as you want to test.
Just to confirm what actually is happening
now because I know this can be confusing,
here is a basic summary.
If you are in the API domain, so that is the
sandbox, if you don't have a key included
in your request and your current rate limit
is three requests per second for an IP address.
If there is no key in the request it looks
at the IP address and if any IP address gives
us more than three requests per second, then
that IP address will receive a status 429
error.
If you are in the sandbox and have a key in
your request and include it in the URL, then
your rate limit will be whatever value is
assigned to that key.
The default value is 10 requests per second.
If you don't do anything you will get a limit
of 10.
If you have negotiated a higher limit with
us, and as I show you on the screen you can
write to us at info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov you can
negotiate a higher rate than 10 . So if you
negotiate to whatever it is, that is the rate
you should see.
What's happening in production?
Basically there are no limits that are key
based on production at all.
Whether you are using a key or not.
You can include your key in production requests
but they are not functional at all at this
point.
So production has no effective limits based
on keys and the sandbox does.
The basic idea is when we go into full production,
the behavior of the sandbox now transfers
to full production.
So IP addresses without keys will have a limit
of three requests per second and if there
is a key present then you get the assigned
rate limit and the default is 10.
Again, another way of reviewing this is if
you don't have a key in the sandbox any IP
that request more than three requests per
second will receive a status 429 error.
If you have a key then by default it is 10
requests per second for that key.
Keep in mind it is any activity around that
key.
If you have multiple people using the same
key, it is the sum of all of the activity
has to be below your rate limit.
So if you have five people, five machines
using the same key, then the sum of the activity
together has to be no more than your rate
limit given that the default is 10.
We measure that rate in one second windows.
So it's a one second moving window and not
a blockage or permanent.
Service is restored immediately whenever the
amount of traffic coming in falls below the
rate limit.
So there is no action you need to take if
you receive an error.
You should have service restored immediately
once the rate falls below the limit.
What will we be doing soon?
We are going to be setting up testing periods
where the behavior on sandbox will transfer
to production for one hour.
We will be announcing them on utilities announce,
social media and also the Insights blog.
There already has been a blog post I will
show you at the end of the webinar where you
can look at these and when the periods will
be.
During the one hour periods when the behavior
production is live it will be under full release
conditions.
So identical to the sandbox.
The money slide is this.
I will put it up for a little time so you
can look at it.
This is when the test periods will be.
There are three of them.
The first one is this Saturday, September
15 from 6:00 p.m. until 7:00 p.m. Eastern
daylight Time.
I also put times up for other cities around
the world so you get the idea.
The next period is September 20 and then September
25 and the times are listed.
It is at 10 AM on September 20 and 2 AM on
September 25.
The strategy is to catch a variety of times
in a 24 hour clock and a variety of different
days of the week.
The point of these is to make sure that everyone
is aware of this as much as we possibly can
make everyone aware.
For your planning, you can conceive of your
software working under full production conditions
during these one hour periods.
So if you have software that has not been
adjusted to accept keys or the limits then
it could be a problem.
The software could receive 429 errors during
that time if rate limits are exceeded.
So without keys, any IP doing more than three
requests per second will get a 429 error during
these 24 hour periods.
If you have a key and go above your limit
you will get 429 errors during these periods.
We will again announce these a day or two
before they happen to remind everyone that
those are the testing periods.
Full release is currently scheduled for December
1 at midnight.
So on December 1, all the sandbox API keys
will become active in production.
Here is the point that a couple of people
have asked about, if you have keys in the
sandbox now you do not need to request new
keys.
Those keys in the sandbox simply transfer
to production.
So if you have keys and you requested them
and we negotiated rates with you and they
are in the sandbox and you are done.
They transfer to production and you don't
have to do anything.
They become active on 1 December.
And one final note is we advise everyone to
continue to use the tool and email parameters
or begin using them if you are not.
These are parameters that have been available
to you for many years and they are helpful
in helping us identify the software package
which is the tool value that is being used
and also an email contact for developer in
case we see a problematic activity and would
like to get in touch with you to help understand
what might be going on if there is a problem.
So the value of email should be a valid email
for a developer who can actually do something
about the software.
The value of tool should be the name of the
software package.
It's possible to have multiple keys for that
individual software package.
So tool is a way of us clustering a group
of keys together around a particular software
tool.
If you have questions about that or would
like to discuss issues with that, we are happy
to do that.
Those are useful parameters and we encourage
you to use them or continue using them.
That's basically it.
I would like to encourage you again to follow
our social media for announcements of the
testing periods as they come along.
There is a blog post I have linked here which
is the second link that describes almost everything
I have just told you including listing times
for the testing periods, including the December
1 date and another things to be aware of.
You can look at the webinars on our learn
page.
Subscribe to the utilities announcements if
you haven't already.
We will post all the announcements to utilities-announce
so it's a great place to get updates on APIs.
If you would like to talk with us in more
detail please write to info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
and if you would like to negotiate a higher
rate key with us or have any questions about
the keys we are happy to set up a call with
you if it would be helpful to discuss it further.
I will be quiet at this point and let Peter
and Dany let us know what you had questions
about.
[Peter Cooper] This is Peter.
We have a few questions I would like for Eric
to weigh in on.
I answered a couple of them but we want to
make sure you get a chance to address them.
One is someone got the impression or saw in
the sandbox it was limit set to 100 instead
of 10.
Is that a bug or are you aware of that?
[Eric Sayers] There was a temporary bug in
the code where some keys were set to 100.
They should be set to 10 at this point and
that should be either fixed now or in the
process of being fixed.
So there were some cases where the rate limit
was 100 mistakenly for some keys.
If you saw that, that is likely what was happening.
My understanding is that we understand the
problem and have corrected it and should be
pushed out.
Contact us if you are having issues with that
or just in general if you see a rate limit
or apparent rate limit that is not consistent
with what it should be, that is likely a problem
so please let us know about that.
[Peter] Another question and I think I know
the answer but want you to confirm it is true,
someone asks how can you see Your key if you
forget it ? I believe it's visible in your
NCBI account.
[Eric] Absolutely.
You just log into your NCBI account and go
to the account page.
Instead of having a button that says create
an API key, your key will simply be displayed.
It's displayed there all the time so it should
not be an issue.
[Peter] A couple of things, this is an interesting
question.
Someone wants to know what you mean by the
testing period?
We want people to try it and make sure they
know what workflows will be like and comment
on that.
[Eric] A couple of reasons for having the
testing period.
One is we would expect that you would want
to make sure that your software works under
the API keys in production.
Many of you have set up your software to hit
our sandbox URLs.
These testing periods allow you to have your
software hit production URLs with the keys
in place.
If it was me, I would look forward to those
one hour periods to run software through the
production E-utilities API service and load
it as you think it might be loaded to make
sure your keys are appropriate and you aren't
getting errors.
If you need higher rates, that might be an
indicator that you need to talk to us so we
can adjust them.
That is the one way you can think about it.
The other and our experience with other releases
like this is we are trying to make sure people
are aware something is happening, and to be
frank, this is a way we get some people's
attention.
There are two main goals.
We want to increase awareness that something
is happening and also trying to provide an
opportunity for developers to actually have
their software work in the production environment
as it will be after December 1.
[Peter] There are two questions about negotiating
an increased rate.
I know you said this but can you remind people
how to go about it?
And what is involved?
Is there a cost involved?
How do we decide whether we will give them
that were not?
[Eric] We are all in the public domain.
Everything is freely available.
There is no increased cost or anything like
that because there is no cost.
What we look at is the level of activity that
your software is producing and that we are
seeing.
So we want to make sure that the API key rate
limit that you have in place is suitable for
the level of activity that you have.
So if it's more than 10 we can help you understand
the amount of activity that we are seeing
from your software.
So if you have tool and email in place than
we can look at the activity associated with
those values in tool and email and report
back to you averages that we see as well as
a maximum rate that we see over perhaps a
month.
We can talk with you in more detail about
your particular application.
We can provide some limited usage data to
you to let you know what we are seeing.
What we are seeing is what we will use to
establish a rate limit error 429.
We simply want to negotiate with you about
what you are seeing, what we are seeing and
what we think is a reasonable rate.
Another thing that has happened in conversation
is we discovered together there might be other
ways you can reach the goals you have for
your software that is not the engineering
that you have now in API.
There might be a more efficient way of doing
what you are trying to do and we might be
able to explore alternative solutions with
you that you could try that might reduce the
amount of calls you need to make which is
good for everyone.
So it's a conversation.
[Peter] Would you remind them how to begin
the conversation?
[Eric] hanks Peter, I missed on that.
You write to info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov and say
what you would like to do.
And if you have a value and tool provide those
and we will get back to you and start a conversation.
[Peter] That email address is on the slide
being displayed right now.
A couple of other things.
We have the two URLs now.
We have the api URL and the eutils URL.
Once we go to production, which one will we
retain a which goes away and those kind of
things?
[Eric] The api.ncbi is only a sandbox and
we won't make that into a production URL going
forward.
The production URLs going forward are not
changing.
You would still use eutils.ncbi the same URLs
you have been using.
There are no plans at the moment to decommission
the sandbox.
I suspect at some point after December 1 once
we see everything has transitioned over correctly
we may decide to decommission sandbox because
it will not be of much use.
Let us know if you would like to have a sandbox
available, we can have it available for more
time.
Our expectation is that production and sandbox
will be exactly the same experience from the
point of view of the keys.
And I know this question has come up in other
contexts, but the api URL at this point will
not be the production supported URL for the
E-utilities at this point after December 1.
It will remain a test sandbox.
[Peter] Another one, someone is wondering
if there will be an API for managing the API
keys.
[Eric] That's a great question.
At this point, point, there is not an API
to manage the keys . It something that's come
up in conversations and the best I can say
is we are thinking about it but no immediate
plans.
[Peter] I think this is the last one that
we will address.
Someone asks because they are using the API
key now, is that basically being ignored or
is it a problem if they use it before the
test period, their software uses the API key
now?
[Eric] I salute you for doing it.
You are doing exactly what you should be doing.
There is no problem with having the API key.
It is basically ignored in production currently
but great you have it there because now you
are done and don't have to do anything.
That is what we recommend is once you get
your keys and are happy with their performance
in the sandbox and have a rate you are comfortable
with, put them in production and release the
code and let it go so you are ready for December.
[Peter] I think that's all the questions we
can address right now.
Certainly if you have additional questions
you can write to us at info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
. We will have the questions written up with
the answers that we gave in the webinar and
maybe some additional information.
It will be available in the materials directory.
https://go.usa.gov/xUdrQ
I think that will be the end of the webinar
for today.
We will see you all next time.